brexit now that the UK has officially
notified the European Council of its
intention to leave what's next the next
steps were agreed by all Member States
years ago and are set out in article 50
of the EU treaty the other 27 leaders of
the European Council adopted guidelines
for the negotiations with the UK those
guidelines can be amended throughout for
negotiations the ministers in the
Council of the EU also meeting in an EU
27 format authorized the opening of
negotiations they appoint the Commission
as the EU negotiator and adopt
negotiating directives on behalf of the
eu-27 the Commission negotiates with the
UK reporting back to the leaders in the
European Council and the ministers in
the council the European Parliament is
closely and regularly informed for as
long as the UK remains a member of the
EU it participates in all European
Council and council meetings except when
breaks it is discussed after the end of
negotiations the consent of the European
Parliament is required the deal is then
ready to be concluded by the council
when the agreement enters into force the
UK is no longer an EU member and the EU
treaties cease to apply to it
find out more on the council website